this is one of the many questions that
will help us see how complex numbers
help us get results and uh conclusions
that actually just affect the world of
real numbers so
let's dive in and have a look it starts
by saying let z
equal cos theta plus i sine theta so
right from the outset we can see
that z is a series of complex numbers
you know theta can take on different
values but it's not just any random
complex numbers we would normally write
a complex number in polar form as
r cos theta plus i sine theta and the
fact that you can see there's no r
that's visible here
means that r must equal to one in order
for z to equal that
so if r the modulus equals one that
means that z must be a complex number
on the unit circle and the unit circle
is a lovely and
important shape which has lots of really
great and useful properties
which will announce to prove this result
we're about to see so
how do we then move forward to use this
result um to do parts a b and c
in sequence well you can see part a says
use demarva's theorem
to show this now this result here i've
actually proved a number of times in
class
and on previous questions so i'm not
going to do it in long form you can see
i've got it
pre-written and hidden here but this
question wouldn't make sense um if i
don't show it to you at least briefly so
let's walk through what this result is
what i can say is by demarcus theorem by
definition
we get this result here you can see that
z to the paraben
has the same effect as just multiplying
whatever our z was we defined it as cos
theta plus i sine theta
and taking the arguments multiplying
them by m and you can see there's a
parallel here when i raised to the power
of
negative n demanded theorem works for
any
integer value of n even negative numbers
so therefore you can see
this is that multiplication of the
arguments but i'm multiplying by
negative m instead of m now the reason
why this is useful to us is because once
we put z to the n
and z to the negative n together in
polar form we can take advantage of the
enormous symmetry that trigonometric
functions have
sine and cosine are odd and even
functions respectively so a lot of stuff
is going to
cancel out and simplify let's watch how
it happens
so here's cos causes an even function so
when you take a negative angle and put
it in you get the same as if you'd taken
the equivalent positive angle
and sine is the opposite when you put in
a negative angle it flips the whole
thing
upside down so that's why sine of
negative n theta is equal to negative
sine of n theta now how does that work
when i substitute that into the
line above well you can see what you're
getting here is
terms cancelling out right when you have
a look at these sine
theta terms or i should say i sine n
theta terms
they are going to cancel i guess you
would call that destructive interference
and then these cosines here they double
up
so that would be constructive
interference and you can see
that's how we end up with the result
that is required of us
in part a so z to the n
plus n to the negative n gives us this 2
cos n theta
term how do i use that in part b
well you can see even though they
haven't say said hence
this z to the n plus z to the negative
it appears not once not twice
but three times in part b you can see
here is z to the n plus z to the
negative n it's just that the particular
value of
n is one you can see it happens again
when you look over here this is z to the
n
plus z to the negative n it's just that
n's four and here you've got n
equals two so what i can do is i can
quote
this result from part a in my proof
for part b and so now that i have a
rough trajectory in my head of where i
want to go
i just need to think about well i need
to prove that left hand side is equal to
right hand side will i start with the
left hand side and move to the right
or will i start from the right hand side
and move to the left
and it looks to me like the right hand
side is considerably more complicated
and my brain is better at simplifying
complicated things rather than doing
that in reverse
so let's start with the right hand side
and see how far we can get
right hand side equals i think they've
got z to the 4
plus z to the negative 4 out the front
with them which have very helpfully
put parentheses around to group to make
it easier to use part a's result
then you've got four lots of
z squared plus z to the negative two
and then what do we have hanging out on
the end there it's a plus six
okay write that there lovely so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
quote that result from part
a i can say that z to the 4 plus n to
the negative 4
is equal to this where n equals
4. so i'm going to say that's 2
cos 4 theta okay i've substituted that
correctly there's not much to do the n
of 4 just goes in there i then say this
is 4 times again it's going to be 2
cos but this time the n value is
different it's 2 cos
2 theta and then that 6 just tags along
so now what do i do here well i'm going
to need to use some trigonometric
identities to simplify this out
remember i'm going to end up with
something that looks like
this which also uses this result so i
need to simplify these meso terms
against something
much more succinct so what i can see
here with cos 4 theta
and cos 2 theta is that both of these
are
double angles in fact one of them is a
double double angle right so what i can
do is i can say
cos of 2x i can state that in terms of
just
single angles of x right i can say first
this is the one i always remember
earliest it's equal to cos squared x
minus sine squared x
but looking at the result i'm trying to
prove there's no science
anywhere so i don't think i'm going to
use that form i'm going to use the
alternative
which is that i can replace that sine
squared with 1
minus cos squared so that gives me
watch out for that double negative 2 cos
squared x minus
1. so i'm going to quote this result i'm
going to quote it
a few times actually because i'll have
to use it a couple of times
in the first instance that 2 is hanging
out the front
and then cos 4 theta the x that i need
to choose to make this relevant is
2 theta so cos 2 times 2 theta will be
cos of 4 theta
so therefore what i get here it's going
to be 2
cos squared 2 theta minus 1.
then what happens here well um the 4
times the 2 that just gives me 8
and then cos 2 theta it's exactly the
same as this except i'm going to write
theta
instead of x that's it so i get 2
cos squared theta minus 1 i add
6. let's do some expanding and then
you're going to see i'm going to have to
do
double angle formula again so i've got
4 times cos squared 2 theta but just to
make things really clear
i'm going to write that as 4 and then
you can see it's cos 2 theta
being squared that's what that's what
cos squared
cos squared that's what it's shorthand
for right i've also got 2 times negative
1 which is minus 2.
what do i have in here so 8 times 2 is
16
and then i also have minus 8 plus 6.
so what i notice here is i've got a
whole bunch of just constant terms here
so i've got what do i have here so 4
the constant terms are all just going to
be equal to let's do it over the end
here hopefully i'll have enough space
minus 2 minus 8 plus 6 that's minus 10
plus 6 that's minus 4 there at the end
and then here i've got cos 2 theta
squared i've already done
cos 2 theta and it just gives me this so
therefore
i'm just going to grab this term here
that's cos 2 theta and that has to be
squared
plus 16 cos square theta that nothing's
happened to so i definitely had enough
space
for that minus 4 over there okay
i now have to look at this and i'm going
to
square that out so i get the 4 still
hanging out the front there let's change
to green just to
clarify what i'm going with here so 2
cos squared theta
squared that's going to be 4 cos
to the 4 theta there's the first part
then i'm going to go minus 4
cos squared theta because i take the
product and then i double it
and then lastly i have plus 1. close
bracket
everything has been squared so now you
can see
all of these terms are hanging out the
end
here doesn't need to stay orange let's
fix that up
and i'm pretty close now right i can get
a lot of terms cancelling you can see
at the front i've got 16 cos to power 4
theta um i've got 4 times
negative 4 cos squared so that gives me
negative 16 or minus 16 cos
square theta and then 4 times 1 is 4.
these terms are still patiently hanging
out here but delightfully you can see
i'm going to get some more cancelling
right
you can see this minus 16 cos squared
and this plus 16 cos squared
they're gone that's fantastic and then
you can see this plus four and this
minus four
they're also gone so they cancel
and now i'm very very close to the end
here right what what is this
well if you have a look um again you
always should have one eye on the
working that you're doing presently
and in a proved question one eye on the
result you're supposed to be proving
you can see here i was working with the
right hand side and i want to prove it's
equal to this
this is something raised to the power of
4. so do i have the fourth power of
something
here and the answer is yes i do 16
is the fourth power of 2 and cos to the
power of 4 theta
is the fourth power of cos theta so
that's
that raised to the power of 4. but again
from part a this this here is just
this but where n equals 1. so therefore
i can use
this result up here i just substitute n
equals 1 here and it
equals 1 here so i'm going to do that i
get z to the power of 1
plus z to the power of negative one from
part a um
so this looks really good right this is
oh sorry i haven't quite finished
um all of that is raised to the power of
four but that is that's the left hand
side
pretty sure let's just go have a quick
look z to the
um one plus into the negative one plus
four to the power four
i'm done so this is the result i was
trying to prove part b
um i can therefore say as required
all right so i'm feeling good i've got
part b
and part a um in my pocket now i just
have to finish out
with part c show that cos the power of
four theta equals
this hmm how do i do
this well it's definitely a hence so
whatever i did in part b
i need to kind of use somewhat directly
in part c
where it's going to have to come in some
way how do i do this well
when you have a close look at part c
this is always the case
with a proof question of any kind right
i did it in part b just now
you want to see where in my previous
working do i have something that
looks the most similar to what i am
trying to prove
when i look through my working where do
i find cos the power of 4 thetas
where do i find cos 4 thetas and cos 2
thetas now
i already know it's meant to be
somewhere in part b and in fact
i can answer this in two ways four
starters
let's use some different colors this is
going to go pretty rainbow right you can
see
right here which i should use blue for
that line let's do it this way
right here wow that is unexpectedly dark
that's better all right there is a cost
to the power of 4
theta right and that's useful to me
because
there is a cos power 4 theta on the left
hand side so that's
that's a start right what about this
where is the last time i saw
cos 4 thetas and cos 2 theta is mixed
together in the same
equation and it looks to me like the
most helpful spot
is let's go to my red here it looks like
it's up here
now you see that that's got cos 4 thetas
and it's got cos 2 thetas
as well so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to take those two lines and
remember
they're in one continuous line of equal
signs right so
these two terms here the or two lines
the red and the blue ones
they're equal to each other so for part
c
i'm going to say directly from part b
i'm going to say on the left hand side
i've got 16 cos to the power of 4
theta so um you can see where i got that
from that was just
right here
like so um so i've got i've got this
result
and i'll just draw the area to be
complete and then i also want to have
this result up the top here so this is
equal to
let's go across back to red 2 cos 4
theta
plus that looks like an 8 cos 2 theta
plus 6 or not 16 it's just 6
right so this is what i get from
this line over here so let's also draw
that dotted line just to make the
connection
very very clear so it goes all the way
around
here okay great now you can see
that from here it doesn't take much
effort to be able to prove
this result let me just uh copy it just
so you can see a little more easily
right i'm running out of space here
let's uh get myself a new
page here okay so this remember
is what i'm trying to prove so i've got
this
cos the four theta and then all these
terms over here everything's almost
exactly lined up
all i need to do is divide both sides by
this coefficient which is
16. so let's go ahead and do that if i
divide both sides by 16 i get
cos to the 4 theta on the left hand side
this is going to be let's just do a long
hand since this is proof 2
over 16 and this is going to be 8 over
16
and this is going to be 6 over 16 so it
couldn't be more obvious that i've
divided everything through by 16.
but at this point here you're pretty
much home right because have a look at
the result
that we're trying to prove 2 over 16 is
1 over 8 that is exactly
the coefficient that we wanted here cos
4 theta
8 over 16 that's a half like i wanted
and then lastly 6 over 16
is indeed 3 over 8. so even though it
was the last
part of this question sometimes final
parts can be very intimidating and
full of very long working in this case
it was pretty simple
part c was it was barely two lines we
just had to identify
the most appropriate spots in part b
where we could use them as our launch
pad
for proving the desired result